j'accueille jean louis aubert
m
je le dois bonsoir
voilà si c'est pour le blind test vous
avez trois semaines de retard désobéi à
trois semaines en plein de l'émission
ils diront je viens vous dire bonjour
ce qui tournait à côté il cite en règle
et il devait revenir pour la cité s'il
est parvenu mais j'avais un concert
acoustique le lendemain pour pour ceux
qui ne savent pas l'enregistrement de
cette émission est particulièrement
marathoniens avaient mission de huit
semaines pour nous et trois heures pour
les spectateurs c'est pour ça qu'elle en
veut voilà donc pour le brent et s3 de
les retards non mais c'est pas grave
maintenant si c'est pour écouter vos
chansons c'est maintenant didier
les
non
buts à
pas mal
g
où
celle sur une étrange idée
voilà ça c'était téléphone maintenant
fin
à
g
mission
côté
de l'autre côté du tout
aussi dit que
qui
g
ici
non
madiran
sur l'est
il y a
je
seulement bon
les gars allez
hier
à
jean louis aubert
et
ça fait pas mal ça fait pas mal de
plumes avant aidera quand on est
beaucoup à la suite comme ça merde aussi
hélas vous revenez avec votre sixième
album solo donc c'est loin téléphone là
d'un coup pour ma main et ouais ça
s'éloigne en tout - la rupture amoureuse
cicatriser c'est pas non je crois que ce
sera jamais ce genre désignera ce tarif
vous dites mais comme on se revoit plus
est ce qu'on s'est vraiment aimé un jour
c'est pas vrai parce que je jouais avec
louis lundi à l'olympia d'abord sais pas
pourquoi j'ai dit ça cette fête samedi
on va trouver l'album s'appelle album
l'album s'appelle est idéal standard si
elle c'est génial parce que c'est à la
fois une marque des chiottes idéal
standard en particulière et en même
temps c'est décrit l'époque c'est vrai
qu'on a tous des hauts standards et
c'était super bien c'est assez énorme et
c'est assez bien trouvés non non mais
c'est vrai c'est un oxymoron jeu comme
la force tranquille
idéal standard cela va ensemble comme ça
voilà les deux mots ça fait un moment
qu'ils me pose une question et je
pensais que c'est un bon nom de groupe
et finalement ça fait un vandale ben
voilà assis penser que son groupe est un
disque assez assez simple c'est
tranquille assez dénudée non les dénuder
et est simple et tranquille
m
je les adore j'adore voir le oui parce
que il est tout le temps dans lequel un
tel repas sera dans cinq ans a fait
partie du tube sna j'espère en tous les
cas j'espère qu'on sera tous là dans
cinq ans alors par le mois donc extrait
d idéal standard nouveau vote nouvel
album enregistré au château d'hérouville
pendant un an alors châteaux d'héroïsme
qui fait dire ça complètement mythique y
avait michel magne qu'il allait qui a
fait là-bas la musique de mélodie en
sous sol d antan flingueurs ensuite il
ya eu des gens aussi extraordinaires que
can eat pink floyd elton john et bitches
assez hallyday et qui peuvent d'idiote
un album avec nous avec night clubbing
exact
et aujourd'hui c'est à l'abandon à
l'abandon a toujours rage pas de
chauffage monacale on était frappé à la
porte
on a dit ce qu'on peut squatter raison
donc fait une petite sous location comme
ça on a eu le studio à qui ça appartient
aujourd'hui propriété des jeunes qui
occupaient le bas du château et voilà on
leur a demandé à eux ils ont dû banon
n'y a rien là haut
effectivement il y avait rien il restait
que le piano d'elton john donc il ya que
le stand où elton john qui va mais le
studio il était lequel quoi vider mon
bon fantastique pièce câlins sont
terribles escaliers aussi à son terrible
c'est là où les bee gees ont fait les
voix de satellites faisant tomber son
épouse tu sais ce dont à gauche pour ça
que vous avez les buts ils ont fait
cette ville sur la rampe
tu es
voilà alors on a regardé à quoi ça
ressemblait à regarder notre caméra
c'est le cas de rouille chez vous et
d'herbes magnéto serge magnette auxerre